hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan Savage
some people think we might talk a little
too much before the trailers actually
start he's go to the doctor
whoa whoa yes ah to figure out have to
learn all these compliment we're showing
up waiting here oh sure now Reina makes
a comeback
nah oh god I love those
how's he so I would know how did you
move after that really just didn't like
his face
who is next
coming 2015 come on man I had to say it
I suppose I had to say it you're right
right I am right you know what's funny
about the last two mortal kombat
trailers mm-hmm I said this game looks
awesome
yeah now after watching this trailer
right Oh Dan totally [ __ ] with you
it's lucky [ __ ] great huh I felt the
calm rage the storm of comments coming
it looks like it looks complicated
honestly I was getting a little
overwhelmed thinking like will I ever be
that good remember all that okay so
they're like three different Raiden
styles from my gathering seeing how
there was three title cards saying like
yes this this and like I have to
memorize well obviously I'll just pick
one or eight and stick with it but like
still yeah yeah yeah in the meantime
while I'm like trying to learn those
moves
I've already had my jerky there stabbed
six times because that's how I do in
fighting games a lot of these killing
moves don't actually kill the character
okay sorry when you break someone's
spine that's pretty good you punched
through his neck twisted his whole neck
yeah and then he need him in the jaw or
something right in the skull all right
let's go let's go that was about the
time I remembered that radians at God so
oh yeah you don't [ __ ] with you God you
don't [ __ ] with gods especially with the
Jesus God you don't [ __ ] with that God
mm-hmm see you straight to hell straight
to hell we talked to you about the good
book roll away do the SUBSCRIBE thing
like subscribe to my channel the real
rejects and you can
subscribe to dance channel that cyber
channel and you yeah I I guest-starred
on his channel recently actually it was
all there was a lot of fun we did scary
games we had scary games so yeah anyway
I'm gonna be comfortable down here look
good for you you know your body doesn't
look that bad anyway guys we're gonna do
some shoutouts rhodius prime oh [ __ ] it
shout out he's been waiting for a
shoutout for like three months he said
oh I'm sorry
rody is prime I'm pretty sure I gave you
a shout-out dude but if you really feel
like you didn't get one then maybe I
actually didn't give you one rhodius
prime but Rodi Rodi Rodi miss ya ready
miss really missed it's like Optimus but
Rho 2 V Rho 2 miss ya what is Rho 2 miss
mean he is of the road okay and musty
and he's in his prime that's cool yeah
I'm in my sexual prime right now rhodius
so I know what it's like ladies if
you're watching comment below and then
message me your phone number let's get
in contact right away but I need valid
proof the earth over the age of 18 okay
please scan identification with that we
promise we won't steal your identity
wing wink nudge II just like use
Photoshop blink it out or some [ __ ] but
I need proof that you are 18
don't ever post your personal
information online I just thought with
your credibility or Animas Prime that I
could take advantage of this moment to
you know promote myself complete online
dating and this is my own version of
online dating it's build a youtube
channel and then ask people if they want
to go on a DVD and if you go on a date I
will be the aqua awkward third wheel
yeah then them will come along too
yeah actually I got 101 days when a date
with Ryan dad will come so fortunately
95 percent of our subscribers are guys
Dondre Thomas sup hey Ryan Crocker dick
crooked dick always give me a shout out
of Irish nevermind Crockett Grabbe dick
dick
hey Ryan a Kroger dick give me a
shout-out I'm Irish in Irish Oh an Irish
who is half Irish what the [ __ ] why am I
so focused on whether or not you just I
don't know but there were some things of
like Irish and Australians so ya know I
started off Australian and then I tried
doing the Irish okay so we've got doing
Irish all right Dondre Thomas yeah my
friend or a [ __ ] [ __ ] you can
soak a lot of good coke I'm proud of
your song go out there don't know where
it is this going Vincent alcorta
Ryan give me a shout out or a punch your
penis with my tongue well see online
dating this guy is willing to suck my
dick he's punching it with my toffee
everybody have you ever been tongue
punched with my my penis sounds like it
would be good that's not what's a tongue
punch hey what's wrong with that tiny
it's a tongue doesn't matter if you're
gag
I don't know big blue yeah no stupidest
thing I've ever hey man Vincent started
this [ __ ] he's just gonna punch you with
he's gonna punch eat the tongue well
maybe you shouldn't just give him a
shout-out and see if he was a girl you
know I would have asked you know for her
phone number
mmm-hmm so she could really do it yeah
I'm trying to send a message out there
got it baby you really wants all of the
female subscribers to please leave your
phone number down below all ten of you
please do we're always hitting twenty
thousand yeah yeah twenty thousand part
of the twenty thousand special is you
get a your way to date with Ryan and I
come along yeah yeah that'd be cool be
cool but I'm like there the entire time
just gonna
mind he's just gonna stare at you no oh
okay I'll make small talk but like this
smallest to talk like so see you shirts
black nice thanks Dan Thanks
do you like pandas